Now that we've got a workable character,
we should probably deal with animation.
We're all familiar with the concept of a skeleton
in a games engine.
It's a series of bones in a hierarchical framework
with joints and restraints applied.
However, in Unreal, the skeleton asset
is also responsible for associating animation data,
not just providing the skeletal hierarchy
within the skeletal mesh.
A skeleton asset can be shared
between other skeletal meshes
and these skeletal meshes
don't necessarily have to match exactly.
Sharing of a skeleton asset
provides a way to share animation between characters
or even entire animation blueprints.
The skeleton asset is responsible for the following.
Animation retargeting,
and this allows animations to be reused
between characters that use the same skeleton asset
but may have different proportions.
It's responsible for creating and storing sockets
and sockets allow developers to place a point
within the skeleton that is offset from a bone.
And this is specifically useful
for attachment of weapons to a character, for example.
Next, it can store animation notifies
and these are gonna be discussed in depth in just a second.
They can store animation curves
and these curves can be used
to drive material parameters, for instance.
Lastly, they can store animation slot names
and these are useful as these can be used
to play animation montages for characters.
A skeletal mesh is built up from two parts.
Firstly, we have the set of polygons
which make up the surface of the mesh.
And secondly, we have the hierarchical skeleton
that will be animated to deform those polygons.
A skeletal mesh stores a reference
to the skeleton asset that it was created from.
Skeletal meshes also hold levels of detailed data
that can be used when considering performance costs
of skeletal meshes in your game.
When it comes to gameplay,
this is the mesh type that we can use
for our player characters or indeed anything
that need to animate based off of a skeleton.
A character will hold a skeletal mesh component
which will in turn hold reference
to a skeletal mesh itself.
Skeletal meshes can only play animation sequences
which are tied to its skeleton asset.
This is important to know
when considering playing animation sequences
on the character.
Animation sequences are the building block
for creating an animation blueprint.
An animation sequence is a single animation asset
that can be played on a skeletal mesh.
They contain all the key frames
from our animation authoring package of choice
that specify transform information.
That being your location, rotation and scale
at a specific point in time
and are linked to a specific skeleton.
We can't just stick an animation sequence
on top of any old skeleton, they need to be compatible.
We can think of an animation sequence
as your looping walk animation asset
or your idly kicking the ground asset.
Whilst animation sequences can be played through code,
it's much more typical for them to be used
as building blocks when authoring animation instances
which we'll touch on in just a second.
They also allow developers to apply anim notifies
which again we will touch on in just a second.
Animation sequences also support animation curve data
which provide a way to change the value
of a material parameter or a morph target
while the animation in question is playing back.
Lastly, animation sequences can generate root motion.
However, in regards to root motion,
you need to consider whether you need this
to be replicated in a networked game.
If this is the case, then animation montages
is what you'll need to use instead.
And that leads us nicely onto montages.
What if we were to have multiple animation sequences
that we wanted to play together?
This is where the anim montage comes in.
Anim montages provide a way to control an animation asset
directly through blueprint or C++.
More importantly, an animation montage can be used
to combine several different animation sequences
into a single animation asset.
Furthermore, animation montages can be broken
into sections which can be played
either individually or in combination.
These sections can also be made to loop continuously
until told otherwise.
Events can be fired within a montage
that can perform tasks such as playing a sound key
or changing the ammunition count,
as well as replicating tasks in a networked game.
Complex animation sequences can be assigned to slots
within an animation montage,
the playback of which can be controlled
through blueprint or C++.
Each section created has a name and a location
in the slot, and we can use this name
to either jump directly to a section of the montage
or queue it up to be played
after the current section has been completed.
To put the above information into context,
if we were to take a reload animation,
we can break the reload montage into the following.
Firstly, a start animation sequence,
a reload loop animation sequence right in the middle,
and a finished reloading animation.
We can combine these animation sequences
and assign them to play within sections of the montage.
Our gameplay code can trigger the start reload section,
cause us to stay within the looping section
as we fill the magazine back up,
and then gracefully transition
into the finished animation section when the clip is full.
So we mentioned anim notifies earlier,
so let's take a look at those.
An anim notify is an event fired from the timeline
of an animation sequence,
letting us drive some kind of gameplay
based directly off of an animation.
Let's take a walk cycle as an example.
We can see in this example
that the notifies can be of a particular type.
A great example here would be the use
of the play sound notify to play the sound of a foot fall
as each foot makes contact with the ground.
We could then expand off of this quite easily
and add additional notifies to draw decals
under each foot to draw a footprint.
As can be seen in this example here,
the Unreal Engine offers out of the box
animation notifies that can be used
to achieve many things.
We can also create our own animation notifies
both within native and blueprint.
We can create anim notifies
by simply basing our new anim notify class
from the anim notify state class.
Anim notifies give developers some key functions
that we can override to achieve our goals,
and these are receive notify tick,
receive notify end,
receive notify begin and get notify name.
It isn't necessary to implement every function.
Your use case might just be that you need
to perform something when an anim notify begins,
or you might have a use case
for doing something over a period of time,
in which case you'd most likely use
the notify tick function.
Above are just examples of the functions
that we've just discussed.
And at a bare minimum,
you should implement the notify tick
and both begin notify and begin end functions.
It's also important to note
that the incoming prompts of these functions
offer up are the mesh component,
this being the skeletal mesh component
of the animation that we're triggering the notify on,
the animation,
this is the specific animation sequence
or montage that is triggering this notify,
and the frame delta time,
and this will give you the time
since the last animation update.
The animation instance is a C++ implementation
from which animation blueprints are based.
They're more commonly referred to
as just animation blueprints.
Animation instances are visual scripts
that are used to author complex animation systems.
So consider your players animations.
As an example, let's take an FPS character.
We'd want to control not only how they animate
when moving in 3D,
that being their forwards locomotion,
but also how they walk backwards, strafe,
crouch, sprint, jump, and aimed down sights.
We'd also want to control
how these animations blend into one another.
This is the job of the animation instance.
The animation instance consists of two separate systems,
that being the event graph and the anim graph.
These separate systems work together
to create the correct pose each frame.
The event graph inside the animation instance
is the same as any other graph inside Unreal.
It's a visually scripted environment to drive gameplay
through a context specific set of nodes.
In this case,
we have access to specialized animation nodes,
such as blueprint initialize animation
and blueprint update animation.
Initialize essentially being the begin play
of our animation with the update being its tick,
with the delta sign being passed in accordingly.
The event graph is where we receive data
that will inform the anim graph
as to what pose to produce.
For instance, we may have set an isCrouchingBool to true.
We'll want the event graph to receive that change
and the anim graph to reflect that change
in its subsequent animations.
It's also important to note that in the examples above,
both of these blueprint events are fired
prior to the animation graph having been updated.
If you find that you need more of an update
post the animation graph update,
then consider using the blueprint post
evaluate function instead.
The anim graph is where the actual pose is evaluated.
We can see here that we've got two potential poses
coming in on the left.
One being that of running and the other being crouching.
The anim graph is taking an alpha between the two
and producing a single result with the blend node.
After that blend node, we have an aim offset applied
because after all in an FPS game,
the player hasn't suddenly stopped aiming
now that they're crouching.
The anim graph takes a base pose
and modifies parts of it to reflect
any additional gameplay data.
The anim graph comes with threading out of the box.
There's obviously a lot of stuff going on here.
So think of all the transformations going on under the hood.
Threading makes a lot of sense
in regards to transform manipulation.
We can enable the multi-threading for anim graphs
by enabling the use multi-threaded animation update setting
in the animation instances class defaults.
Of course, with any threading,
we need to take into account its safety.
And there's a few things that are broadly safe to thread.
Those things would be the anim graph nodes themselves,
such as the ones we can see on this slide.
We've also got directly accessing any member variables
such as the is crouching member.
And then finally, any blueprint pure functions
as their cons, they're not going to modify the state
and are thus safe to access on other threads.
We also have the ability to enable fast path optimizations,
which are enabled in the project settings.
This essentially enables the anim graph
to access internal variables directly
without having to copy them from the native
into the blueprint virtual machine.
Of course, this does come with caveats.
If we're intending to modify that value,
we'll lose out on that optimization.
And as such, it's useful to have
the native animation instance class
make any changes that you would want
before having it bubble up into the animation graphs VM.
State machines and animation layers
can be used to organize
and break up animation functionality.
We can see here that we've got separate nodes for idle
and for running with a transition link between the two.
This lets us set up a spoke node layout
for each state in isolation from one another.
These links can have conditions applied to each other,
preventing certain states from blending into each other.
So in the above example,
the run state can blend into the jump start state,
but jump start can never blend back into run.